[Musik]
ein luzerner unternehmer kämpft um seine
firma chroma bringt das unternehmen zum
stillstand
eine künstlerin muss alles absagen
denn ist so dass drei lohn haben gruner
gefährdet ihre existenz sozialstunden
wurden nicht als höhle lucens größter
souvenirhändler ist fassungslos der
touristen hat es gehe
wir sind wir und zwei luzerner freunde
betreiben ein hotel
sie geben alles um das haus zu retten
ihre geschichten in luzern in corona
jahr
[Musik]
luzern im frühherbst 2020
das milde wetter sie die menschen nach
draußen die corvette 19 fallzahlen sind
niedrig steigen aber leicht an auf
schweizweit 500 neuansteckungen pro tag
im hotel rose d'or wird es nach dem
vielbeschäftigten sommer ruhig
je nach geschäftsgang ist auch die
gefühlslage der betreiber ein stetiges
auf und ab
wenn den 35-jährigen hoteldirektor
manuel berger zweifel packen
helft der gang in den hauseigenen
boxkeller
[Musik]
der ansonsten so besonnene hoteldirektor
manuel schlägt zu ein sinnbild dafür wie
das kronia zu einem immer längeren kampf
für uns alle wird das macht mir mehr
spaß sport und musste so konzentriert
aber es können
auf der brache in emmenbrücke wird die
rettung des alpen varietés kaleidoskop
gefeiert
[Musik]
claudia kienzler hat die schaubude einen
monat vor dem schotter und im frühling
übernommen
[Musik]
zum ersten mal können freunde und gönner
rinnen des varietés den stand der
renovationsarbeiten begutachten
auch claudias mutter ist gekommen und
mit ihr die ganze familie
so schön
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ein verein hat das variete gekauft als
geschäftsführerin kämpft claudia um
dessen weiterexistenz heute will sie mit
der unterstützung ihres freundes
christoph den gönnerinnen und gönnern
die finanzielle situation aufzeigen
noch
der gott des bundes events solange es
noch warm ist und der kultur und der
musik übergeben
danke dafür dass ich das mache das
publikum genießt den anlass aber für
claudia geht es um mehr
für den betrieb muss sie 200.000 franken
auftreiben sind und das interesse hält
das ehemalige profi war gedemütigt zur
folge es bliebt spiel und verzehr
theater dass ich mein wunsch dass auch
kulinarisch sehr viele künstlerische
programm wird sie und dass ich mit dem
grund dass koch ist für präsentiert
kursniveau
es wird er dort einmal prüfen ob sie
ganze spielplatz mit dem zweiten also
ganz luftartistik peter doliwa oktober
es sind riesige investitions lästige wo
jetzt mit tätig werden
das ist aktuell natürlich britischen
beitrag leisten
die arch und leistungen finanziert und
dann künftig auch die wirtschaft in den
verein
jeder zustupf ob groß oder klein ist
willkommen
denn ohne spendengelder droht dem
varieté projekt das aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das fest gibt schon mal einen
vorgeschmack auf die varieté toni im
frühling 2021 will claudia und ihr team
mit akrobatik tanz theater und kulinarik
durch die schweiz dingen so der plan
[Musik]
roland k
der ceo des zelt bauunternehmens
hunziker ag trifft seine berufskollegen
vom neu gegründeten dachverband sie alle
hat die krise mit großer wucht getroffen
es befinden sich 15 bis 20 prozent
umsatz wo man jetzt eure manchmal
ungestüm
also hör oder also so eine sagte
weltlage zu schätzen war die mehr
irgendwo viel für 70 bis 80 prozent
umsatz verloren haben maßnahmen ist wie
vor mitglied anlagen flüchten jetzt klar
sehr schwierig mit und mit selber trägt
sehr gut möglich
aber keine selbstverwaltung politik
ausgesetzt sagt im moment was man darf
und was nicht und wie immer übernimmt
für und hast gar keine sicherheit also
du kannst die gesamte infrastruktur
aufgebaut haben und am tag der
türöffnung wird dir wird die
durchführung versagt das bewusstsein z
am 28 februar 20 20 grad und ich rede
vom 20 21 maschinen werden sie und da
hätte schon irgendwann noch mal einen
punkt du zeigst du ein um man nervös
wird sagt jetzt morgen rahmen gehalten
werden
sie stehen wieder anders werden schaffen
für die ermittler mitarbeiter bewertet
heiko entlang
[Musik]
noch im sommer hat roland können seiner
belegschaft ein großes versprechen
abgegeben
keine kündigungen bis ende jahr im
herbst gehört die touristen stadt luzern
wieder den einheimischen
der sommer viel gas schweizer gästen für
einige hotels besser aus als befürchtet
so auch beim hotel bonjour das beflügelt
direktor manuel berger das hotel war zur
hälfte ausgebucht immerhin dank
spezialangeboten und dem sommer kiosk
besuchs macht ist dass mir selber kommt
endlich der individualgäste dass er
schaffe das ist nicht einfach nur ein
richtig für diesem konzept sondern mit
diesem hotel ist über das man nur 28 10
das gegen lok ist die stadt und
vordringlich keiten und so dass mehrere
große gruppe hatte also gar tourismus
und natürlich kann heute also im
normalfall gruppe tourismus jetzt
natürlich nicht gut weil das war alles
weg oder wie man mit reisegruppen aus
asien indien und china zusammen schafft
ist das ist ja alles kennt wurde
[Musik]
doch jetzt mit den kälteren herbsttagen
gilt auch die unsicherheit im kleinen
boutique hotel zurück
[Musik]
es ist ende oktober die neuansteckungen
steigen an
auf über 9000 pro tag die zweite
pandemiewelle hat die schweiz voll
erfasst restaurants müssen um 23 uhr
schließen
anlässe über 50 personen werden verboten
doch kleinere kultur anlässe sind noch
nötig monatelang hat claudia kienzler
mit dem ensemble für ein theaterstück
geprobt heute ist premiere
das lampenfieber dementsprechend groß
jetzt individuelle lösungen für müssen
und dann am zenit aber war nicht der ich
bin konditionell ist dass morgen die
würde ich sagen
[Musik]
die tickets sind begehrt und alle drei
vorstellungen ausverkauft
[Musik]
das stück für kinder dreht sich um das
leben die freundschaft und den tod
[Musik]
wir stimmen
eine ente ist wütend und hadert mit dem
tod
doch dann freunden sich die beiden an am
ende kann die ente in frieden sterben
wie kindern den tod erklären in corona
zeiten der wind diese frage an
aktualität
[Musik]
endlich wieder eine theatervorstellung
und endlich wieder ein verdienst einen
solchen applaus hätten wohl alle
kulturschaffenden die harte zeiten
durchleben verdient gotthelf und ich
habe sowieso was jetzt kommt man immer
um spiele xiii und am walther und
mitglied seiner spieler aber da was auch
gelang
dieses glück kann claudia nochmals
genießen alle vorstellungen finden statt
aber dann muss das theater wegen corona
wieder schließen
[Musik]
nur ein jahr vor dem ersten showdown hat
casagrande in ein neues geschäft
investiert nicht wie bisher souvenirs
sondern luxusprodukte sollten gut
betuchte touristen aber auch
einheimische anziehen
frage beantwortet sind fasane faire
produkte gibt erzählt alles was man
sieht ist 24 karat gold und es ist es
wahnsinnig schwer wo eigentlich
staatsgeschenke genossenschaft wenn sie
so sein könnte und dennoch ein kleiner
wird das meistens so verschenkt 6500
franken muss einem der goldene käfig
wert sein
aber abnehmer gibt es keine
die nachfrage nach luxusprodukten ist
eingebrochen
[Musik]
fast alle gaza grande filialen senkt
geschlossen über 100 angestellte in
kurzarbeit
dieses geschäft bleibt zwar offen doch
auf kundschaft wartet das personal
vergebens
im moment ja sehr viel geld investiert
wenn man sagen
die kann man sieben millionen und 22
millionen ist war greifbar also das sind
immense summen durchgang und am ersten
mai von einem jahr im beruf gemacht und
sehr gut laufe der athenischen das
natürliche produkt fertig sie im märz in
mir sind wir kaputt wisse dass do liste
denn wirklich mit schweiz mit
personalschulungen wollte casagrande die
flaute überbrücken doch auch die sind
jetzt in frage gestellt behandlung
schulung wird am zweiten november nicht
durchgeführt wenn heute der bundesrat
entscheidet dass dies verboten ist für
mehrere personen und ich erwarte dass
das abgesagt wird für den moment und
dass wir das erst weitermachen können
casa grande ist vorläufig noch liquide
setzte zusammen und versuchen lösungen
zu finden mit dieser informierte dass
die jugendlichen petit mir tipps was bis
jetzt noch nicht passiert ist ihr werdet
es in einem vorbereitungsgespräch mit
den banken und hoffe natürlich jetzt
sehr stark auf die rtv außen will mit 1
prozent rückgang von dem namen das
wirklich ganz schlimme situation ist für
uns das privatvermögen schmilzt im
prinzip mini hand tut mir weh ich muss
jeden tag endet wie sport beruf machen
und das geld weder die firma ist
und ja das ist sehr viel geld
nur wenige meter vom luxusgeschäft
entfernt befindet sich das mutterhaus
von corsa grande
auch wenn keine touristen vor den
vitrinen drängen wie in zeiten vor
corinna gibt es für den hauswart immer
etwas zu tun
bojan jovanovic arbeitet seit 25 jahren
hier und ist stets zur stelle wenn es
probleme gibt
sie gibt links das ist laut bauer also
wo die vitrine macht also gemacht hat
und jetzt muss ich probiere vor die
innere siebte hartz iv und das kann ich
auch
mission impossible das heutige sache
sieht man nicht also man sieht ob es
schön beliebte und gut und recht aber
rein machen drei bestickt oder so haben
wir das lösen und mit seitige sache denn
sich weniger lüthe was meinste bauerntag
geschafft
peters
manuel berger und seinem
geschäftspartner walter willimann steht
im hotel bosse so ein wichtiges treffen
bevor denn es steht nicht gut um das 28
zimmer haus in den wintermonaten buchen
nur wenige gäste trotzdem belaufen sich
die betriebskosten auf gegend 30000
franken pro monat
peter kirche ist der besitzer des hotels
auch ihm machen die tiefroten zahlen
sorgen und der bundesrat verschärft die
maßnahmen weiter
china sieht die not der betreiber und
kommt ihnen großzügig entgegen
der umsatz kann ja und dann noch einmal
der nacht der bücher wieder deuce
wenn ja wofür man dass man das so
irgendwie eklig und köstlich richterin
zahlen s gott dass ich positiv das gold
scott www.start unterstützt ramonet sie
wenn wir das auftauchen die mit dem
täter und der erste täter ist weiterhin
bereit die das wussten wir und das
cluster peter richter
mitunter kühlen und gerichtskosten grand
slam steve erhalten werden weiß unseres
gut gut zusammen
das hotel hat peter keller von einem
freund der keine nachkommen hatte geerbt
er glaubt an manuel und vieh und ihre
kreativen ideen und peter besprechen
dann müssen wir halt ab dass das normale
handwerker eine ganze zeit über hat es
aber wir haben dabei gewisse etwas das
einfach mal sein peters bleibt also
natürlich alle gene besitzt eine
wäscherei auch die spürt die krise
trotzdem bleibt er ein sozialer
unternehmer und ist sich nicht zu schade
mit anzupacken
das schönere rose scharf an trotz
unsicheren perspektiven bleibt gelassen
und optimistisch dass das wiederum dazu
kommt muss ja gar nicht gestellt mit
einer terrasse für riester verlassen und
macht da ist immer gut da
[Musik]
der umbau der terrasse sorgt nicht nur
für muskelkater und hunger sondern auch
für neue kosten also 20 30 uhr kosten
tiefe einnahmen und wieder greift der
besitzer in die tasche hat peter
investiert ist auch kanada das
hoffentlich auch partizipieren und mit
mir dementsprechend gute jungs machen
mit dieser terrasse
der verbiss bringen die terrasse war
außerhalb der 20
was ist das langfristig sind ja mal sie
firma zugute
heute zusammen
einen verheißungsvollen namen für die
neue terrasse hat manuel auch schon
borussia lido
[Musik]
nur wenige hundert meter luftlinie vom
varieté in emmenbrücke entfernt gibt es
ein ganz spezielles dorf es besteht aus
lauter wagen und ist das zuhause der
musikerin claudia kienzler
die 39 jährige künstlerin hat sich hier
ein einfaches leben aufgebaut
ihr zuhause ist naturnah nachhaltig und
mobil
[Musik]
eigentlich hat sich das so ergeben glück
könnt wo er wohnt und haben sollte
abonnieren bagger kommt bis er sich die
ganze stelle reichow bin und dass ich
vor so dass ich mein eigener wagen
[Musik]
claudia hat sich bewusst für diesen
unkonventionellen lebensstil entschieden
denn freiheit ist für sie der größte
luxus auch wenn es manchmal viel arbeit
macht
claudia hat momentan nur das feste
einkommen ihres kleinen pensums als
musikdozent und violine lehrerin
obwohl sie ausfall entschädigung vom
kanton erhält reicht es nicht zum leben
darum muss sie auf erspartes
zurückgreifen
das ist fahrlässig gelegt haben
schumann altersvorsorge das ist
eigentlich eine mini altersvorsorge
sparkonto ich war jetzt braucht wird
natürlich bin ich froh fest dass das
ganze wirklich und in ried ziele steckt
ich habe eigentlich mit plans sie sich
sehr krank sie auch noch etwas ist das
irgendwie so berufs gleise das dass das
museum kalkar das und den hang hinter
das kostet das ist sicher ein großer
extrem bewusst was sie für freiheit
haben weil ich hinten und ab und zu auch
brasil bewusst was was auch noch kein
handy und im irak orten vorstellen
und das macht zusätzlich mein mann sagt
aber es wenn ich sterbe oder älter wird
dadurch das gefühl ich kann
grundsätzlich gegen das lebensziel
verfällt
die ungewisse zukunft zehrt an den
nerven und die ständige bereitschaft zur
flexibilität ermüdet umso wichtiger sind
für die musikerin momente der ruhe
denn nur wer frei im kopf ist kann
kreativ sein
[Musik]
bojan jovanovic den mann für alle fälle
bei casagrande haben es uhren besonders
angetan
mit viel leidenschaft erledigt er
einfache reparatur arbeiten
doch seit ein paar tagen stehen für
beuern die zeichen der zeit leider
schlecht wie aus heiterem himmel hat er
die kündigung erhalten
verstanden
corona kein tourist geschafft gott nicht
so gut und plötzlich gestellt was heißt
das für mich was heißt das in der
familie sind und so hin sind immer aus
politik an karabatic
ja und was kann ich machen oder hat so
viele sachen überlegt und denke es ist
ein schock
[Musik]
auch den ceo der zeltbau firma hunziker
ag zwingt die korona krise in die knie
roland können sieht sich gezwungen sein
versprechen an die belegschaft zu
brechen
alle mitarbeiter den job
scobel echten vergnügen
essen red und wir reagieren
und leitet
sechs mitarbeiter entlohnen
der ganze prozess von
entscheider welt trifft das kleine das
vereinsleben
gleiche aufgabe sondern die andere in
der eu und ein anderer arbeitsplatz wird
die entscheidung treffen und den
ansätzen und ideen alle das
kommunizieren
für rossi hütter von der
geschäftsleitung eigentlichen führend
aber jetzt im aufnahmen der griffe dass
ich das ist jetzt steht das letzte
kündigungsgespräch an eine mitarbeiterin
verliert ihren job
nach vielen jahren in der firma
[Musik]
hausrat bojan jovanovic muss auf ende
jahr gehen
trotzdem ist auf ihn nach wie vor
verlass so schwarz da hatte ich ja da
haben wir das ganze ja ich kenne sich
aber ja
da wusste oder nicht stylish wenn man
läutet dann ist es aber wenn man
allerdings mit einer lok das kabellose
aufbau anlastet die aussicht schwer dass
er in wenigen wochen ohne arbeit sein
wird
er ist einer von zehn angestellten denen
gekündigt worden ist
ja das ist natürlich sehr sehr hart die
einzelne person und ist die diskussion
in der geschäftsleitung sind über tage
gegangen weil die position dass wir im
moment nicht braucht und es ist leider
einfach der die position jetzt passiert
und bei anderen natürlich auch wo immer
seite der stadt rief er die orks einmal
keine rolle
und deutsches besseres so lange dass die
rütner jung sind das und möglichkeit
händler besonders finden und bayern ist
sicher eine gute chance
[Musik]
bojan ist 50 und vater von zwei töchtern
beide sind mitten im studium seine frau
nina hat einen teilzeitjob als
verkäuferin
ab und zu leisten sich die beiden ein
mittagessen im thai restaurant noch
dürfen gastronomiebetriebe geöffnet
haben
er hat mir da hat zu dem fehler zwei
also parade zum petri wechsel
das sieht so schön danke für ihren hat
nina erst in der schweiz kennengelernt
die beiden sind schon lange ein paar
zusammen haben sie höhen und tiefen
durchgemacht und jetzt die kündigung
alles macht und dass er jetzt ja das hat
mich wirklich schockiert
das war so viel setzt hoffnung verloren
wäre das beste ihre person schafft das
ist wie bojan ergeht es vielen menschen
in der schweiz innerhalb eines jahres
steigt die zahl der arbeitslosen von
120000 auf 170000 an
[Musik]
roland kühn erlebt seine schwierigste
zeit als chef der festzelt firma
hunziker ag wegen der krise müsste er
sechs kündigungen aussprechen
[Musik]
soeben hatte das letzte
entlassungsgespräch geführt schwarz lag
schöne schwarze und dir die stadt zwar
also die stadt zwar weise nicht auf
diskussionen
jetzt komme ich jetzt schlicht mitbringt
für die mitarbeiter die mit arbeiten die
aber natürlich dass elise thema ist
wieso er habe briefe einfach nur spaß
wenn man so einen tag gott geschaffen
und weise morgen für das war eine
gemacht für das immer wieder zu machen
ist nicht schön definitiven verübt und
könig
[Musik]
vor weihnachten gilt wieder die phase
rot die maßnahmen werden noch
restriktiver
trotzdem wollen viele nicht auf
weihnachtseinkäufer verzichten
der bundesrat schliesst alle restaurants
kultur und freizeitbetriebe die folgen
der wirtschaftlichen misere werden immer
sichtbarer
sogar das 5 sterne hotel schweizerhof wo
schon die englische königin übernachtet
hat schließt im januar für drei monate
seine tore
auch das hotel bonjour geht für sechs
wochen in den winterschlaf manuel berger
will die zeit für renovationen nutzen
doch die frage bleibt wie wird es
weitergehen
das gefühl kann ja noch einen halben tag
spaß wie die fdp aber das ist noch gar
nicht so klar dass das sagt immer man ja
wir angst hatten dass jetzt knirscht
abenteurer hotellerie dann aber dass
sich auf absehbare zeit wie stellt das
ist auch das wohl mit meinem gesicht
macht
[Musik]
das jahr voller unsicherheit ist
anstrengend für den hotelier der das
haus vor drei jahren übernommen hat und
so ganz andere pläne hatte zwar musste
niemand entlassen werden
doch jetzt scheint es dass auch manuel
langsam von corona müdigkeit erfasst
wird
das hotel wird geschlossen
währenddessen weht die fahne auf
halbmast
das starterset und amerikanisch oder
kliniken brüder hat das mal zu wir haben
es zu machen
in der letzten folge hauswart bojan
jovanovic ist auf arbeitssuche
böses erwachen für mich weil mich nicht
verkaufe ich bin so wie roland können
wird von seinem chef einbestellt der
will expandieren
das sind ganz große chance wir natürlich
der große wie drucker sind die dem markt
waren wir jetzt endlich klarheit hand
hier aus wie in der schweiz auch nichts
bringen dann du mir das sehr genau
prüfen und das varieté wäre schon fast
bereit für die tournee
[Gelächter]
[Musik]